as we told you at the top right before
we came on the air tonight we heard that
the actress rose mcgowan wanted to come
on and talk about something
we've never met rose mcgowan uh before
but we're completely open-minded
we just learned how something's with
britney spears who we've not
interviewed since she was literally a
teenager but apparently we have just
read she's been under a conservatorship
for the last 13 years and this has been
in
the news flew under our radar but it has
been and rose mcgowan
has been watching it too and has
thoughts about it she joins us now
roswell thanks so much for coming on
tonight
hi tucker nice to meet you too i also
have an open mind well
this is my favorite quality in person
thank you um
so i'm coming at this cold i
again haven't seen britney spears since
2003. i just read she's been under
conservatorship
i make the case if you would what is it
and why is that bad or good well
in my opinion and in many others it's
bad
imagine you're a 25 year old young woman
or young human who has been forced to
perform
since as long as she could walk to
support
her family her father put her under
conservatorship
at age 25. many in the media laughed and
scorned her
when she shaved her head i lived in
hollywood during that time and i've made
it my life's mission to tell
all of you out there what so many of you
really know deep down
that fame and hollywood and the media
machine
are rotten to the core and they do hurt
and they do damage
at age 25 her father and a judge ruled
with many paid off doctors help that
britney spears had
dementia so
since then she's gone on to do a
five-year residency in vegas
two shows a day she's gone on a tour in
2018
and what happened today is literally a
cultural landmark
moment it is a cultural reset she got to
speak
for the first time i believe in her life
honestly
and openly and what has been done to her
is horrific and i know it seems like why
should we care about a rich pop princess
right
but i think it's deeper than that and i
think it goes to what you talk a lot
about which is
the rock in the machine and how
society also plays a part in a weird
form of oppression
man i mean you've pushed all my buttons
i i have to say
i mean the idea that the individual
is crushed by forces larger than her
and that deep down it really is rotten
and that
people are treated as disposable objects
rather than as
human beings with souls i mean that's
all that's all on display every single
day
so pardon my ignorance but quickly
conservatorship means she can't make
basic life decisions for herself
absolutely none
she can make no decisions when she sees
her kids
uh what medicine she takes she said
today britney spears said they put her
in
lithium that is an incredibly
helpful drug for some but a hardcore
drug
she said she was doped out i'm
summarizing and she
i think is ready to blow the lid she
said today she's
so angry it's insane and i understand
that kind of rage
after being the sorry go ahead
no no i know i didn't i didn't say
anything i'm listening intently
oh sorry i heard something so you know
the thing is
i was the first one to go on the record
about harvey weinstein and that kind of
sickness
and the people that are truly putting
your entertainment
in your head and while we've all been
entertained by britney spears she's been
being tortured and i know
it it seems like one person but they've
done this to women and humans and
whistleblowers
and people they don't like and and
really like you said tucker
the people the monsters of power that
control the
puppet not just her but like the message
it sends to every girl or every boy out
there
that you are disposable and the elite
can own you
so i think it matters i do i think the
individual matters
above all and if they can destroy one
person they can destroy everyone i i
know nothing
but what you just told me but i think
you make a really compelling case i love
that you care
and i'm really glad that you came on
tonight rose mcgowan thank you very much
i'm honored thank you tucker thank you
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else